Instead of reporting the width in
the number of physical hardware pixels,
the browser reports the width
in the number of dips, or
device independent pixels.
As its name implies,
a device independent pixel is a unit of
measurement, that actually relates
pixels to a real distance.
The idea being that a device
independent pixel will take up the same
amount of space on a display regardless
of the pixel density of the display.
>> So if there are twice as
many hardware pixels across as
there are pixels
reported by the browser,
the Chromebook pixel must have
a device pixel ratio of two.
>> Right.
The browser has a viewport width of 1280 DIPs.
The 1280 dips get scaled
up to 2560 hardware pixels.
When the page is
rendered on the display.
>> Back to my un-optimized website.
What's the browser doing,
when the viewport isn't set?
>> Unless you tell the browser
that your site was designed to
work on a small screen it
assumes that they weren't.
And renders the page, as if it were
on a screen that were 980 DIPs wide.
Now, imagine that content
being scaled to fit on
a phone that's only 360 dips wide.
It gets scaled to less than half.
Yuck.
It then tries to make
the content look better,
by doing something called font boosting.
The browser tries to pick the primary
content on the page and scale it up.
>> Oh, wait a second.
So now the browser's actually trying to
guess at what content is important?
Sounds like a problem.
>> Yep.
That means that some fonts are large and
easy to read.
While others remain small,
and are really hard to read.
Users will have to spend a lot of
time pinching to zoom in order
to see and interact with the content.
>> That is not ideal.
>> Nope.